I never expect to be sued as a doctor  and thinking is settling am I supposed  to do what you want me to say rich  suppose I was one of your patients what  do you tell me I tell you to fight yeah  [Music]  they found that body in the morning  they're gonna come looking for us  I'll search that you you should have  suspected bonds robbery earlier this  evening  I hate doctor  [Music]  is that him yeah that's him this is  perfect  i slayed it in my mouth  my brother already has your wife and get  your operating doc my brother guys I'm  gonna kill you I'm gonna kill your  daughter  I'm gonna kill your wife I'm gonna kill  your dad we gonna be okay  used to be the big dog in town don't try  anything I start cutting bite on this  [Music]  we have to take control  [Music]  I'm scared my love for you Atlantis  what are you gonna do I'm gonna fight  him  [Music]  get out of here now  [Music]  and Tufts on a [ __ ] huh  [Music]  [Music]  you